if you are happy you must be louder the
reason there is so much anxiety in the
system is because the small percentage
of angry and hurt are so much [__]
louder than you we must change the
communication game be the bigger person
I have talked at nausea of the concept
that negativity is louder than
positivity the disconnect between what
is happening in here in conversation to
what's happening on Discord and Twitter
is astonishing and let me tell you
something that has become wildly Crystal
Clear four five six people can be ten
times louder than [__] six thousand
if you are a human being that is lucky
enough to be happy content it is your
responsibility to society and Humanity
to get louder about it unfortunately
most people counter people that are
dropping pain on them with more pain
back and it becomes one big [__] game
of pain ping pong